we are taking phone calls at 6 1 7 830
for 750 that's the number for callers we
will take any questions comments etc I
believe we have our next call we do have
our next goal okay name in town who's on
with us and what do you want to talk
about oh hi David um first of all I
would like to say that I'm a big fan of
your show thank you thanks for having me
and I would like my name is Carlos Neos
comp and I'd like to talk about
integration and I'm an immigrant in the
United States myself and i believe the
immigrants when they moved to apprently
can actually spend money you know by
education and I myself actually am an
entrepreneur and I employees floor
people and I feel really proud of that
and I have to say I've been really on
edge with this whole election and really
concerned about Donald Trump and has
told the quotation force idea not to do
it wouldn't affect me personally could
like legally I don't think because I'm
here legally yeah you know an American
citizen now Alice I am have a green part
ok I think you're married to an amicus
yeah so yeah but my concern is that you
know the implications of having a
deportation force and that you'd need
probably something like concentration
camps and things like that so my
question is like how can you know I
think that the last bush that the
Trump's are going to try to put forward
it's going to be about integration
especially since the Republican Party
has somewhat left him so I think that's
going to be a big thing that you got
that's interesting yeah and if we let
Carlos up just a tad if we can so I can
hear him a little bit better I think
Carlos that this entire deportation
force thing even if Trump is elected is
not going to happen I i think if Trump
were elected
after four years he would claim to have
had a deportation force really what
he'll just have is the system we have
now where there are circumstances where
we have agencies here that enforce
immigration law and deportations happen
there's regretted deportations happening
under President Barack Obama what what
country did you come in the u.s. from
out of curiosity I came from Brazil okay
so I think that there is not going to be
number one I mean this is this is so
insane that we're even getting into
these details but Trump's focus has not
been Brazil right i mean his focus has
been Mexico and other is sort of Central
American spanish-speaking countries that
are people are as he says coming in
through Mexico etcetera I really don't
think that that that there's uh I think
it would be insane in terms of what it
would represent to have someone like
Trump with the ideas he's espoused about
immigration be President of the United
States but I'm convinced a lot of what
he says would happen just won't i I'd
there won't be a deportation force and
the wall with Mexico if it gets built
partially Mexico is absolutely not
paying for it so I share your concerns
with the rhetoric I don't think much of
it will come to reality thanks so much
for the call Carlos all really really
appreciate it okay thank you all right
now we are gonna move on a very
interesting to hear from Carlos gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com /
TDPS